[Music]
all right hello hello
so uh as uh tay just said i've really
enjoyed lunch thank you for having me
it's so good to be back at jscon
budapest it's been six years since my
last time returning to budapest and to
jsconf so thanks again for having me
it's good to be here
[Applause]
nope
spoilers for later uh so
welcome to my talk offline first iot all
about building connected devices without
relying on the internet empowered by
javascript
so as tiga said my name is nick hair i'm
a staff software engineer on the front
end platform team at betterment which is
a financial robo advisor in the us
despite the robo part of that
description i don't work on iot for my
job this is just a side project and a
hobby
i have been an active and empathetic
contributor and
open source maintainer in the past
and since the beginning of the my career
occasionally uh given that opportunity
to help maintain some of the projects
i've contributed to uh and i like to
spend time away from the computer not
working on iot and other things
on long bike rides and at my local
climbing gym
so here's what we're gonna go over today
uh the table of contents by the way is
toc uh and uh so we're gonna talk about
a little quick overview about iot in the
real world before covering what the heck
i mean by offline first if you've never
heard of that before
and then we'll dive into how we can
build iot devices offline and how
javascript can help out with this
and then finally we'll wrap up with what
you can look forward to and how you can
get involved with this whole process
so let's start with the state of iot in
the real world
i think
most if not all of us here and maybe
online are familiar with the phrase
internet of things uh it's generally
associated with like the smart home and
remote sensors and controls
on embedded and internet connected
devices
the iot ecosystem is often an easy
target of ridicule
and given some weird ways it can fail or
be oddly integrated into everyday life
i don't think i ever want to see an
email like this telling me that some
sort of thing that my pet depends on
is going to have a service outage
and as much as we like to make fun of
these broken experiences many of the
working use cases end up connecting the
world to our most private spaces
intentionally or not
this default behavior of most smart home
integrations doesn't sound very smart or
safe to me
along with security issues this
dependency on the stable internet
connection prevents our gadgets from
being resilient to the realities of
practical usage in our homes
i like to call this diagram how many
services does it take to turn on a light
bulb
the services behind our devices put
unnecessary delay into the operation of
these components for the roughly 10 use
case of controlling them outside the
local network
not to mention the unexpected
obsolescence when those remote services
are deprecated or shut down entirely
this is insteon which basically shut
down completely overnight uh it was so
bad that the ceo wiped his history from
linkedin that he never worked there ever
so i'm sure there's a whole big story
about that that just happened recently
and this is where the offline first
philosophy comes into play
so i said this phrase a few times now
offline first
folks may have heard about mobile first
during the early days of responsive web
design and mobile app development which
was followed by offline first back in
2013.
offline first is the idea of treating a
network connection as a progressive
enhancement for applications not that
they should always or only stay offline
many native applications operate in this
manner because they are embedded into
the device or operating system with no
guarantee of internet availability
web applications assume
the opposite because you know it takes
an initial connection to get the app
onto your device in the first place
but that's not assured to be true from
that point onwards
so introduced in the early days of age
205 when application cache and local
storage and web sql were the state of
the art
these days we have improved tooling in
the form of progressive web apps and
using service workers and newer newer
storage apis advertising the advantages
of installable offline web applications
i learned about this way uh first way i
learned about the offline first way of
development while contributing to hoodie
oh
there we go uh contributing to hoodie
which uses pouchdb as a client
client-side data store that would sync
with an external couchdb when a
connection was stable and available
this architecture also allowed the
client side to react to certain events
and changes in that data store through
those events emitted by pouchdb and
hoodie itself
so as i said before
we want to treat being online as a
feature rather than the ability to go
offline as the future you know offline
first expectations
connectivity and data freshness should
be communicated to the users provided
sensible fallbacks
rather than showing an endless spinner
or an error page when an unstable or
there's no interconnection at all
syncing data stored with a with new
remote data that local data with the
remote stuff
will always have conflicts or will have
conflicts eventually so you should be
prepared to handle them either
presenting that to the user let them
choose what's new or what they want to
keep or by some other strategy you want
to entail
working this way on the web
has heavily influenced the way that i
think about internet availability and
how much our devices rely on them to by
default
so how do we apply this idea of offline
first to as progressive enhancement to
the internet of things
so these are my general guidelines when
i like to put connected devices and
services into my own home or any sort of
personal private space that i have
so as i said before uh so there should
be a physical fallback this is always a
need for me especially anything that
should be key and important this can be
turning on lights unlocking doors all
that sort of stuff should be able to
available again offline either by a
physical fallback or by being able to
sync remotely through some other source
locally
communication with a device should be
again local on the nokia network by
default over preferring an external
service any connection outside that
local network should be secure
preferably end to end encrypted
and approved by the owner of that device
you know permission base where you're
very used to that on the web when we
want to access some sort of part of the
user's data in terms of their location
or navigation any of the sensor stuff
that we saw previously
should be approved by the person who's
going to be affected by it
and then use of outside services should
be
seen as progressive enhancement so
having that sensible fallback when it's
not available
and then any over-the-air updates
should be opt-in unless absolutely
necessary for security patches as we saw
before if you have a service outage
because your
microwave or your coffee maker try to do
a wi-fi update in the middle of trying
to make something that just doesn't feel
good
so how can these connect devices
communicate without the internet i mean
what are they actually connected to at
that point
well there are many ways available to us
ranging from direct one-to-one messaging
we have pub sub models publisher
subscriber
uh and even mesh networking available to
us on the local network
and each strategy has its pros and cons
so direct communication could also be
called client server communication and
this is the relationship that they hold
with each other an http server could be
running on a local device that is
exposed to the network and clients can
send those requests to it as long as
they know the ip address or maybe a
local host name
similar
to that bluetooth devices can advertise
and have multiple clients connected to
them in order to receive information
we'll talk about discovery a bit later
but that's one of the core downsides to
this approach since these devices or
services need to be aware of the
available servers and hosts to manage
those connections manually
pub sub or publisher subscriber
communication provides a way of emitting
or listening to information without a
direct knowledge of the source of that
information
well websockets could be considered pub
sub based on their usage they have a
direct client server relationship in
terms of how they connect
and they require that connection
management exactly
multicast udp allows for a fire and
forget pattern communicating over the ip
on the local network and has resiliency
to devices or services disconnecting or
joining the network at any point in time
although it lacks some reliability uh
since there's no required
acknowledgement from any of the
receivers when they send that message as
i said fire and forget
that's where mqtt really shines as a
messaging protocol that requires a
centralized broker but has stronger
guarantees around if and how many times
a message is delivered
it's quite popular in the iot space
including brokers like mosquito
the broker's piece usually becomes a
point of friction since it requires an
additional long-running device on the
network in some way
and then mesh networking is one of the
newer and more popular forms of getting
into iot communication because this
allows for nodes or devices or services
to connect directly dynamically and
non-hierarchically
to as many other nodes as possible and
then to cooperate with one another to
efficiently route data to and from
different clients
z-wave is a proprietary mesh protocol
that requires specific hardware to
communicate over a lower radio frequency
than wi-fi
so it uses less power while shipping
smaller packets of data over time
zigbee is based on the same frequency as
wi-fi while providing a low power
protocol built upon low rate wireless
personal area network or lrw pan
which provides the building block for
six low wpan or ipv6 over low power
wireless personal area networks
this is used by thread
and so thread is quickly becoming an iot
standard through an industry working
group including samsung google apple and
many more
it provides stronger encryption ip
addressability and self-healing
reliability
as i said before we need a way to
discover these various devices on our
network we don't just always have a
domain name to go hit
but we sort of do so
one of the hurdles in creating resilient
services that they may appear disappear
from the network at any point
domain name service domain name system
service discovery or dns sd
falls under the xero com for zero
configuration networking set of
technologies
it allows clients to discover a named
list of service instances and to resolve
those services to host names using
standard dns queries it was proposed at
apple in the 90s and implemented in 2002
under the name rendezvous later changed
to bonjour
they really like the french names for
this sort of configuration it seems like
dns sd is advertised over the local
network through multicast udp as we
described before
called mdns so multicast dns
and it was resolved to the dot local tld
so if anyone's ever seen something on
their network or been able to connect to
like my thing.local that's over mdns
it was used by apple to for local server
and peer discovery for applications like
safari ichat messages
as well as seamless airprint support so
our printers generally these days are
serving some type of local server and
advertising themselves to other devices
in order to say like hey you can print
to me here's how to connect to me and
here's how to communicate
it was supported it's also supported by
many linux distributions through the
avahi driver and there is bonjour for
windows which usually used to require
installing itunes in order to make that
work
so as i said before
the i like some of the apple devices
because they already advertise this type
of stuff and so homekit
uses its default behavior of
communicating only on the local network
and then delegating any sort of remote
communication through a hub and so those
hubs can be an apple tv an ipad a home
pod any of those types of things just
stay in your network and then our
end-to-end encryption is for end-to-end
encrypted as far as the communication
with any of your devices outside of the
network
and home k homekit currently operates
over mdns for discovery and uses http
for communication or bluetooth for both
sort of responsibilities
and here's where you clap when i drink
[Applause]
thank you
and as tiger said before he mentioned
home assistant home assistant is another
way to add that sort of local first
communication and control with some
additional flexibility and expanded
options due to the open source community
that provides integrations to this
software
however it takes a bit more know-how and
expertise to manage it correctly um you
have to have some sort of device that's
always running it and so that's a bit of
server management and not everybody's
ready to get started with that
although home assistant does provide a
system for integrating with z-wave
zigbee and mqtt which
homekit currently does not
all right so finally getting to the
javascript part of this we're at a
javascript conference after all
so how does this popular language fit
into the world of iot
well starting off we have a very capable
server-side environment for node.js that
can be used to control headless linux
devices like a raspberry pi or
i'm very preferable to the tesl2
among others
the tesla 2 is an open source hardware
project that i helped contribute to and
maintain that provided a friendly
onboarding experience handy apis for
working with wired
also known as pinned are pins
and wireless communication that's all
the sort of networking stack that we had
available while supporting most of the
mpm ecosystem
packages such as johnny 5 allowed you to
control all sorts of sensors and
peripherals across many development
boards including the tesla 2.
these devices are relatively small i
have a few of them on stage today
compared to traditional servers
or laptops or any sort of
desktops that we have available in our
home while consuming much less power to
boot i'm currently powering several
right now just off of regular usb
batteries
but how about supporting even smaller
form factors like microcontrollers that
don't include an operating system that
can be powered off of a tiny lipo or
coin cell batteries
this environment is usually reserved for
system languages like c or rust or c
plus plus well
custom javascript engines for embedded
devices are actually not very new at all
my first experience with them was with
the pebble smartwatch
which ran a fork of a engine called
jerryscript which was provided by
samsung
this enabled for full stack wearable
javascript applications that could run
on your phone and your wrist
the espreno project has been around
since 2012
and actually has its own smartwatch as
well called the bengal.js and they just
recently came out with the second one
so if you want to have a wearable
javascript application on your wrist
check that out
each of these implementations come with
caveats or limitations for developers
who are used to modern javascript apis
uh in the browser and node such as
promises async await classes etc
the sum this assumption has changed with
the introduction of moddable xs in 2017
and i'm obviously a little biased there
model bull is focused on shipping a spec
compliant engine two microcontrollers
currently supporting esp8266
the esp32 and the raspberry pi pico
boards
and providing apis for interacting with
common sensors peripherals wireless
communications and displays
it has been used in production
environments including appliance
displays like microwaves and ovens
it's also the first if not only engine
to implement ecma 419 standard for
javascript apis on embedded systems who
here has heard of ecma-419 before
okay no one as far as i can see from
here well
tc53 is the technical committee behind
ecma 419 and was formed in 2018 to focus
on the ecma 409 standard
i-10 tc53 is an invited expert through
my experience with tesl
and tc53 is bringing the benefit of
standard apis to embed a systems so
creators of hardware products can
benefit from rapid api rapid development
and scalable scalability enjoyed by web
developers
to achieve that tc53 is focused on its
efforts on javascript
and use javascript
to expand beyond the web into embedded
systems powered by resource constrained
environments and devices
unlike tc39 tc53 doesn't have any sort
of formalization of stages of proposals
just yet as we heard about through the
types as comments or type annotations
proposal we heard yesterday morning
but there is work to share annual
updates to the spec each year the first
version shown here
contain information about peripherals
and sensor interfaces
while this year has been the committee
has been working on further refining
those interfaces and adding additional
initial networking apis which i really
care about
ecma-419 heavily uses classes and
methods for event listeners which could
be contentious for a lot of typical
javascript developers however this
interface makes it easier for
implementers and library authors to
layer on top of it
once this exam one such example is john
e5 embedded or j5e
and takes advantage of this approach and
provides a more friendly and familiar
api to anyone who's used to johnny 5 or
more modern approaches to javascript
and working with all sorts of hardware
components
another example is building on the
upcoming upcoming networking apis of
ecmo 409 is the implementation of fetch
available on embedded devices through
monable so now fetch it will exist in
microcontrollers in node and in the
browser so fetch has finally happened
it's there it's everywhere
[Applause]
all right so let's dare the demo gods
once again today
attempt to show off the concepts that
i've just been talking about
uh but first a tiny story so this is
about a home kit clapper
in the summer of 2019 i just moved to a
new apartment with a bedroom that had no
overhead lights and no convenience
switches for the available outlets in
the room
since i was renting i wasn't about to go
do some electrical work into the room
but it was becoming quite annoying to
stumble through the dark in order to
activate a light
when my wife would joke about being able
to clap on the lights so for anyone who
has not heard of the clapper before
this is a guy that's been around for
quite a long time and sits in the outlet
and listens for claps to toggle to power
on
this device still exists today you can
buy it
anywhere uh and
while that could work for my use cases i
want to be able to also control it from
my phone
this is when i looked into kind of the
one of the gateways of getting an iot
which is a connected outlet or smart
outlet rather than replacing all the
different light bulbs within my home
and it doesn't require a separate hub to
work and you don't need to ever worry
about it running out of power because
it's just always on
this enabled me to use home homekit to
control the outlet so i look to my shelf
of devices to figure out how to trigger
it with sounds
as i said i'm a little biased towards my
tesl2 development boards and it's
associated light and sound sensors that
are available as plugable modules
now how do i send this information to
home kit or just the outlet
enter home bridge
so home bridge is a very capable and a
very capable raspberry pi
i could write a plugin in javascript
home bridge runs in node.js
to communicate with my tesl
so rather than depending on an external
service like i mentioned before like
adafruit io or azure iot hub which are
fine services for more expansive use
cases
i wanted to stay
local and keep my messaging offline
so i could create a plugin that ran a
local web server that could hit endpoint
for toggling light and
that would require some knowledge about
the ip address of the raspberry pi
running the server
or multicast dns local host names as we
mentioned but to keep these two devices
completely separate and resilient to the
ups and downs of network communication i
chose to go the pub sub route through
multicast udp
and for those who have never seen the
dgram module it's been around in node.js
since nearly the beginning
and is the building block upon which
mdns is built for node.js services
this is how homebridge actually
advertises itself to homekit
i wrap this module into a usable
familiar event emitter interface so any
device on the network could subscribe to
and subscribe to and emits events just
like any other component in an
application
so let's take a look at the tiny bit of
code that i have available today
so this is the program that's running on
a tesla that is currently sitting up
here with me right now
not in the box uh and so we're going to
pull the tesla module which actually
lives on the device itself um grab the
ambient uh sensor package which is
available on npm we literally print the
npm package name on the device itself or
the module
and then the multicast eventer mod
package that i made and just pulled into
this program
and then we're going to create a new
sensor
object using the port on the tesla
and a new instance of our multicast
emitter that we'll just call our
publisher
and we'll set some thresholds for what
sound within trigger
the event on the sensor as well as how
long we want to wait between claps to do
the double clap
inspired by the clapper
and then we have some kind of state
management in here
to track some stuff and so we're going
to wait for the sensory tell us it's
ready to start listening for events and
for sound and then set that
configuration to our threshold or
trigger level
and then on the event of the sound
trigger which will happen once we
reach that threshold or pass it then
we're going to clear it out and then
reset it again to set up another
listener
and then once we have
if we have a first clap state then we're
going to clear any timeout that we have
and then
emit the clap event on our publisher and
then set the state back to no claps
otherwise we're going to set our first
clap which means now we've just heard
the first one and set a timeout to see
if we haven't don't have another one
within the threshold amount of time then
we're going to reset it back to its base
state
all right so you've been very patient
it's time for a demo so we're going to
see
i'm not touching anything
ta-da
so that is actually
uh this little device is running behind
the box with my tesla and it's just a
little sensor running on battery power
and i'm not running on any internet
connection except for one wi-fi network
that's running off of a tesla over in
the corner over here so this wifi
network is currently called offline
first of course and not connected to the
internet whatsoever it's just a shared
backbone for the wireless
and the last demo uh is a more recent
prototype that was motivated by the time
at home with my wife during the pandemic
she would never know when i was on a
video call because i had this screen
that blocked me from the rest of the
apartment
so i explored building a connected
on-air light to help communicate this
status whenever my webcam was active
so this is what it looks like as you can
see on stage for those who are up close
it's literally a paper prototype it's
made out of a box i got from adafruit
i carved in on air on there put some
paper in front of it and it's filled
with this it's not much to look at
although i was very careful going
through airport security as tiger had
mentioned earlier as well you don't like
to see wires poking out of stuff so you
gotta be very careful and the battery is
not connected whatsoever um
and so
this right here
is actually being served by the device
in front of me this is actually an
iframe going to onair.local within my
local network
and
it's just running
off of a usb battery and it uses just a
regular form there's no client-side
javascript actually running this at all
to
trigger the form controls and http
responses so as we see here if i go and
click on the light
we should see the light come on
it's a little tough since i'm getting a
bunch of stuff here let's go over to the
so here lights on right now
there we go
lights off there we go i can control
also the
color here so now we have a blue light
and now the real trick
is does my webcam work
so luckily i'm using slide dev those who
have never used it before and there's a
nice little view here
which will pull up my webcam and we can
see here
the light is now
on because my light my webcam is turned
on here i'm gonna
show that over here
it's on i've not touched the form at all
i've just only touched the the webcam
itself my webcam's off
and now my honor light turns off as well
[Applause]
so this is all running using a
background process i have written in
node.js as well on my computer that just
is looking for events that are streamed
through mac os to say when the webcam
turns on is then we'll send an api
response to the local web server running
oakley and then triggers it on and off
um it's been great fun to build on it
and i hope to make it even more
resilient as well as we do with the
clapper
so where do we go from here
so
i want to really improve the starting
experience for any new developers to
embed environments
and working with these newer apis
and newer systems so i created a cli
called xs dev to help make automating
the setup and usage of modable much
easier and much more expected by folks
who are used to using like create react
app or npm or mmpx create block right
and so these five commands allow you to
install that cli globally set up the
initial tooling for your environment
whether it's mac os or linux and windows
support is coming soon and then also set
up the necessary
drivers and everything needed to build
stuff for the esp32 which is what i used
to run in my on-air light
you can also have it set up for the pico
there's a wasm support as well to run
certain prototypes in the browser
and then you can create a new project
where i called this one fetch happened
and i can use an example template from
moddable in order to just create the
initial sort of code that you can run on
your device and then you can cd into
that directory and do excess dev run
device
and you point to esp32 and it'll find
the one that's connected to
your laptop over usb
and even without if you just wanted to
run an initial setup then you could
without anything past the just excess
dev setup you can run it in a simulator
and just start trying the code out
yourself
instantly
now future projects i want to focus on
and start to really push the boundaries
of what we can do with javascript on
these embedded devices
so i wanted the ability to discover
devices on local network through web
apis we heard a lot about installable
web apps and be able to do stuff offline
i'd like to be able to expose that
through web bluetooth or webmdns maybe
at some point a web wi-fi
to be able to do that discovery and have
locally installed web apps
have an ecma 401 419 compliant runtime
on top of node.js so we can run on these
embedded linux environments like node
and tesl with the same code that we ran
on our super tiny microcontrollers
having a homekit accessory protocol also
known as a hap library for moddable
since we have homekit and home bridge
for node.js let's make it just as easy
to run on these tiny devices and make
them look like any other integrated
device on our network
and then securely expose those external
services to the local network to get
data we saw a great example of this with
tiger's approach of using web hooks
integrating with home assistant and then
exposing that to his phones that he had
running locally
and so things to check out after you're
done with the conference and done with
this talk
so this is the technical committee where
you can find the ecmo 419 spec where you
can see all of our meeting notes
and even learn how to participate and
listen in on those meetings as well
this is the monable project itself the
open source
code check all the examples
documentation available there this is xs
dev which is that cli i was just showing
you over to get started and just start
testing out this environment
and then j5e the j5 embedded so if you
don't want to just do networking and
start doing stuff with robots and be
able to remote control cars and boats
and all this sort of stuff check out j5e
thank you and happy tinkering
[Applause]
you